suivez le guide
l'exposition annuelle de l'association
art pour tous commencent cette
association basée à saint joseph
présente les travaux réalisés par ses
participants au cours de l'année elle
propose plusieurs ateliers d'activités
artistiques peinture sculpture cuisine
ou encore musique robert à 20 ans il est
concerné par des troubles autistiques
il participe à plusieurs ateliers mais
sa préférence c'est la musique ne fait
pas que j'ai reçus en formule 1 va pas
couper m gay
ce à quoi je pense à je pense amis de le
faire ses oeuvres sont réalisées dans un
contexte particulier art pour tous comme
son nom l'indiqué à poser la mixité au
centre de son projet cela permet à
robert et à tous les participants de
rencontrer sur un terrain commun les
personnes concernées ou non par le
handicap c'est l'essentiel pour nous en
fait c'est c'est vraiment ce qui anime
l'association
cette diversité des publics alors autant
au niveau des générations que au niveau
culturel au niveau des milieux sociaux
mais aussi bien sûr avec la diversité
des personnes porteuses de handicap
puisque on accueille des personnes de
tout handicap confondu au milieu de
personnes dit on va dire ordinaire cette
mixité se fait dans la simplicité
ici les intervenants ne sont pas tous
des professionnels du médico social mais
aussi des artistes des passionnés tout
se passe au travers de les changes
ma formation de base c'est soudeur donc
c'était pas souvent le joaillier des
personnes handicapées 1 et là bas j'ai
découvert autre chose de différent et
ça m'a quand même pas mal à porter ça
m'a permis de voir la vie différemment
de voir les gens différemment en fait
c'est plutôt un échange parce que du
coup moins comme j'ai pas de formation
j'interviens d'une manière plutôt on va
dire naturel j'ai pas j'ai pas les codes
qu'il faut faire comme ci comme ça moi
je vais intervenir en juste avec mes
émotions c'est vrai il faut que j'essaie
de faire comme ça avec telle personne
c'est vraiment de l'individuel on peut
pas travailler on travaille en groupe
mais c'est chaque personne à son son
individualité ses caractéristiques il
faut savoir faut savoir jouer avec et et
apprendre à connaître les gens en fait
moi je le vois plutôt comme ça c'est
plutôt le fait d'apprendre d'avoir envie
de connaître les gens qui fait que ça
fonctionne on est maintenant sur une
équipe de 15 à 20 personnes qui
interviennent chaque semaine mais
attention bien sûr tous ne sont pas des
salariés
même s'ils font partie intégrante de
l'équipe certains sont des bénévoles
beaucoup d'ailleurs et sont tous animés
par une dynamique de le faire ensemble
faire ensemble vivre ensemble mais je
crois que ça s'articule manière un peu
spontanées dans cette atmosphère de
légèreté propice à la rencontre et à
l'expression les différences s'effacent
on le fait de changer de public où on va
plus aucune différence arrivé à un
moment handicap ou des handicaps il ya
plus de différence moi j'en suis fier
vraiment parce que c'est rare de voir ça
en fait est extrêmement mixte on a des
gens qui sont handicapés uns des autres
si son nom
qui n'ont pas de qui portent pas de
handicap ont des gens en fauteuil
tout mélanger les couleurs de peau aussi
il faut et voilà fait ça fonctionne très
bien il ya aucun problème je veux m'en
volet là au delà
regardez là il ya des chansons qui
respire la liberté donc c'est plus
facile pour les enfants pour apprendre
la chanson ah oui se sentent bien et
puis ben ils apprennent plus vite ici
c'est naturel en fait c'est pour ça que
je dis ça ça respire la liberté en fait
c'est inconsciemment nous savons e et sa
soeur margot qui est non voyante et
trésorière de l'association
elle a aussi sa vision de ceux qui
créent ici pour moi c'est comme un arbre
c'est comme les arbres ya des feuilles
ah oui branches différentes quoi j'en
viens d'acter la musique il ya la vérité
qui fait de la sculpture et la peinture
mais tout ça bon tout ça forme un tout
comme elle participe aux ateliers exposé
échanges au travers de son oeuvre
l'histoire d'une dame qui lui dit un
jour il y a à la télé c'est qu'il ya une
petite fille qui sait en équilibre sur
un ballon j abois mais oui mais elle ne
tombe pas je dis non et ça m'a marqué et
jusque maintenant quand il ya eu cette
année le thème du cirque
l'exposition ça le revenu en mémoire
exprimé son regard partagé son
expérience sans craindre les préjugés
voilà ce que permettent ces ateliers
animés par les artistes d'art pour tous
une démarche d'acceptation qui permet de
mieux se comprendre mieux se connaître
et parfois de se trouver des points
communs
le but de l artiste c'est sage et de
prendre un peu de recul et finalement
les handicapés comme on en parle et ben
ils ont pas le choix de prendre du recul
pour pour que ça se passe bien trop leur
vie voilà ce qui se rejoint c'est de se
dire bon j'ai envie qu'on vous me voyez
moi pour me voyais réellement qui suit
et comme là qu'on voit que c'est surtout
donc je pense que là
c'est là où on se rejoint si la
personnes porteuses de handicap aussi
elle veut se faire accepter par par les
autres pour ce qu'elle est et pas pour
ce qu'on peut voir avec le fauteuil ou
avec une canne dire que j'existe en tant
que personne
le monde plus rien ne m'étonne
en plus il ya deux méthodes
ne plus rien de méthode